our fourth speaker of this session is
Antoine P Cohen professor P Cohn is the
G where travelstead professor of the
history of architecture and technology
and co-director of doctoral programs at
the GSD and professor P Cohn teaches
history in the theory of architecture
and technology professor P cone received
engineering degrees from the coal
Polytechnic and from the coal Nationale
de Beaune tichel say an architecture
degree from the coal ducted architecture
Deborah V lemon and a doctorate in
history from the cold altitude and see
on social he works on the history of
architectural and urban technologies
from the 18th century to the present and
his most recent book digital culture and
architecture an introduction for the
design profession was published in 2010
excuse me and offers it a comprehensive
overview and discussion of the changes
brought about by the computer to the
theory and practice of architecture
professor P Cohn is now also developing
an essay on ornament professor bacome
welcome you thank you very much thank
you for having me with you today in
tomorrow he's drawing dead it's a
question that is worth asking because
they are other disciplines in which
drawing died a long time ago I began
actually my career by studying
engineering history and if your study
engineering history you discover that
actually by the mid 19th century the
practice of drawing as the basis of the
engineering profession began seriously
began to decline very sharply and very
rapidly so he's roaming dead in
architecture this is definitely a
question but the question is obscured in
my opinion by at least two phenomena the
first has to do with the diversity of
roles that growing used to play and
still play very often from the earlier
stages of conception to the final
rendering phases
what is taking
place today is perhaps more a shrinkage
of the spectrum of these users than a
disappearance proper of drawing the
second phenomenon is the thick layer of
physiology professional ideology that
has always a companion the question of
drawing from the Renaissance onwards
indeed drawing played a fundamental role
as we all know in the very definition of
the architect as opposed to the various
craftsmen that contributed to the
realization of buildings so because
before discussing what is happening
today with the rise of digital tools and
culture what I would like to do is to
examine a bit more closely these two
phenomena this is in my opinion one of
the condition to be able to understand a
little better what's happening today the
diversity of roles played traditional E
by drawing striking by comparison to its
present function in our computer aided
design age drawing was the tool and okay
keyboard yes well keyboard seems to be a
resisting - well as you can cheat so
much I'm helping you nowhere thank you
one of the limits of the digital so
drawing was the tool for the first
sketch and more generally for the core
task of conception and here we have the
famous initial sketch of Paxton or one
of the first initial sketches for the
Crystal Palace drawing was also a tool
of communication towards the client and
the public at large and the Lenox
library of John Dixon hunt this drawing
is a good example of that finally
growing surf to communicate with the
artisans and workers of all kinds that
intervene in the building process but
beyond these roles drawing was also a
mean and it has been outlined there is
time this afternoon to explore the
visible world it was a tool of
investigation also of the underlying
structure that were supposed to organize
this world one of the function of
drawings was among other things to
relate the natural and the human realms
the visible world was indeed a mix of
natural and artificial objects and its
underlying structure were supposed to
bridge these two domains this is it's
quite interesting by the way that
Violette Leduc the 19th century
architect famous treatise on the role of
drawing is twelve and a senator history
of a draftsman insist a lot on this
relation between the natural and the
artificial the natural and the human
with a couple of ideas one of them that
comes again and again in the history of
a draftsman is that nature actually is
the first draft man and a pretty amusing
illustration is this picture in which
what the draftsman does is actually to
emulate nature's power for daily nation
and we see on the on the left the lines
on the cliff of on the french side of
the channel and the master draftsman in
a way teaches his pupil to emulate
nature when he explains to him the
principle of altitude court or lines so
Nature had already done something like
that on the cliffs a light nature
the draft man must was supposed to draw
overtime the drawing was not only a
practice it was a lifestyle and an
ethics and this is the meaning of the
moto at the beginning of yelena dudich
new lady s seen a Linea this is why I've
chosen Violetta to do because it
provides a good transition toward the
ideological role of drawing in
architecture drawing enabled the
architect to appear both as an artist
imparted with an individual genius and
as the natural coordinator and rulers of
the other crafts and trades involve in
the realization of buildings and I spoke
of the relation between nature and the
human it's worth noting of course that
genius designated originally a natural
disposition and genius enabled you know
very literally to bridge the distance
beat the alleged distance between the
natural and the human and this was one
of the thing that the talented artists
could do and actually the drawing of
ornament had something to do with that
by extending from the initial sketches
that carried the essential idea the
first thought to the graphic documents
necessary for education drawing was
supposed to be the guarantee that a
seamless flow linked the various stages
of design and realization some this is
an idea that is still quite present in
the 20th century for example if Jean
proved a conception of design and the of
drawing and the way he relates drawing
to what he called the constructive idea
that is to say the essential impetus the
essential dynamicism of you know the the
the constructor thought and practice is
something that is clearly related to
that and pouvez insisted constantly on
the fact that drawing was just you know
the embodiment of this flow that led
from the initial thought to the
prototyping and then possibly industrial
realization now this traditional set of
rolls of drawings is definitely
challenged by
computer and I'll come back to this
issue in a moment but once again the
question of what is act exactly
happening today is often obscured by
this diversity of role played by growing
and very often we tend to confuse all of
them and and it's probably worth in some
ways paying more attention to the very
situation in which drawing used to
appear and once again it is also made
difficult by what I would like to call
an anxiety there is an anxiety with
drawing today and that has to do of
course with what is may be the role of
the architect by the way it's worth
noting one century and a half ago
engineers when drawing began to enter
into engineering drawing it began to
enter into a crisis they had a very
similar kind of anxiety about where was
engineering going so growing remains for
sure today very present in a lot of at a
lot of moments it's present at the
beginning and at key moments in the
conception process and it seems to me
very improbable that this is going to
disappear but on the other hand drawing
has lost part and a large part of its
role in the communication with a client
and above all as a tool of communication
between the various profession involved
in the realization of a building we have
entered the age of computer generation
views and animation for the better and
for the worse ban and even more the
you.they age of beams the Building
Information models which are clearly
replacing substituting themselves
database in some ways are replacing
tradition some of the traditional
function imparted to drawing so the
pending question is whether drawing will
lose also its role as a privileged mean
to explore the visible world and
investigate its underlying structure in
a way drawing as a form of humanism and
there again being an historian and since
this is an historical session one could
perhaps have talked a little bit more on
photography because photography created
a very similar set of issues and during
the second half of the nine
since entry and and the east wall and
the senator of the history of a draft
man of Viola Lou Duke is written by
somebody who's very aware of the impact
of photography and actually viola
collected photographs he had a
photographic collection so and this is a
question that will go on during the
first decades of the 20th century and a
lot of studies have shown for example
how reinforced concrete is a mode of
construction but also an architecture
that develops in an intimate connection
with photography this is an in big
construction site but even more
interestingly a scholar like national
ago has argued that these weird and
kitschy realization by in big is
photographed in a way very close to the
kind of new objectivity that modern
architecture a few years after the
production of such drawing the
construction will use to photograph the
buildings so it is perfectly conceivable
that documenting or surrounding visible
world will be more and more CIMMYT
somatically delegated to a complex mix
of digital media including photography
video blogging it might be true that you
know we spend less time and we attach
less personal memory to a single digital
photo but let me remind you that we
takes hundreds of them today it's almost
movie like we take also little movies we
blog we do all these things that create
the thick layer of experience through
digital media
so in summary drawing is certainly not
disappearing but it's true that
something like a vital thread link
linking conception and realization
design and the exploration of the
surrounding visible world design and
design speculation seem to be fragile
seems to have become fragile to the
point that it could be even broken so
why does this perspective creates such
an anxiety because it seems to endanger
once again something that appears
precisely as vital both to the dish
finishin of the architect and to his
status with
his professional partners I think this
is reinforced by a very curious
professional situation which is namely
that the generation that is now in
command in the arc in architectural
practices is usually a generation that
do not master the use of the computer
it's actually the younger one who do so
it's a very strange world in which even
many of the so-called digital architect
actually delegate the manipulation of
software etc to younger so why do we
however if we go beyond that have this
impression of something vital that was
that a companion traditional drawing
uses and this is where and this will
echo strangely despite our differences
of orientation threat equal orientation
what you Annie said before me this is
now where one has to introduce another
fundamental dimension in the affair the
body or to be more accurate the relation
between mind hand and material medium
and material medium that is and what
seems and this is where the hand I had a
picture of their hand but which goes
lost in the final version of these
PowerPoint but this is we've seen a lot
of hands before so just imagine just
image in a hand so the question is if
what seems to be lost is a creative
immediacy that digital media doesn't
seem to make possible is can one however
recapture search immediacy by an
appropriate combination of digital media
and this is perhaps one of the question
raised by the eclipse of glowing today
so since I'm playing the role of the guy
who likes digital technology even if I
cannot push a button and the computer I
I will personally take the position that
such an evolution is actually not only
possible but that it will take place
it does not mean and I'll come back to
this issue toward the end of what I want
to say today doesn't mean that
necessarily all is good with such an
evolution actually technological change
is rarely entirely beneficial and
something is almost unavoidably lost in
any kind of transy technological
transition but no but nothing in my
opinion but our own ideological
prejudices enable us to conclude that we
cannot recover some kind of vital link
between our mind and the world through
the use of digital media and
phenomenology for example which is often
mobilized to justify these hypothesis
often make also another hypothesis which
is that the body of man is not as
flexible as it is actually and speaking
for example so the there is a lot of
flexibility in our body and without
necessary entering into a discussion on
cyborg oriented prosthesis posthuman
perspectives etc I would like to go back
to this idea of body image it's true
that the hand the hand for example is
present in your brain and this is part
extremely present but on the other hand
the brain is constantly wiring and
rewiring itself and partly in contact
with the tools that surround it and just
like the the brain rewired itself when
we began to be surrounded by simple
tools like hammers except rather than by
more complicated machine what is very
probably my very probably the happening
in the future is a rewiring in which you
know the mental image of the body will
change in relation to the use of digital
tools you have also a number of
neurologists today that say for example
that the use of the thumb
image in the brain has grown with the
use of Gameboy among teenagers and it's
true that you know the hand has not
really disappeared even if it's very
concentrated into a couple of fingers
with many of the digital natives
so what from Gregory Bateson to Bill
Mitchell what married many theorists of
digital media have suggested that
is that what is actually taking place is
a radical extension of the body and also
reframing of its sensorium so let me
just insist on this thing also when the
computer appears almost everyone
believed that equals a computing machine
hence its name and then very rapidly and
this was the phone no man and authors
revolution one discovered that it was
actually as much a logical machine today
the digital revolution might mean that
we're discovering third phase that
actually the computer is also as much a
machine to experience a mush machine
through which our senses are in a way
redirected way interpreted etc we listen
already through a very awful digital
media we see through digital media you
know if you talk to younger kids for
example a non clickable image on a non
zoomable image is a kind of oddity I
very often tell my students that the new
form of authenticity in a museum is the
non clickable image which is the only
difference today for many kids between a
painting and what they see on their
computer so this we we are also
confronted to so among the features of
this new sensorium I would make the
hypothesis that there could very well be
a stronger interaction between the
various senses synesthesia is definitely
among the characteristic of the new
emerging sensorium senses are in an even
stronger interaction than before one of
the consequences in my opinion of the
digital is to provide a basis both
epistemological and practical for these
interaction we are for instance in
architecture confronted to a new tact
ability and the kind of blurring between
the visual and the tactile and so many
ornament I don't know what I did out
here came my hand so it was a total
inversion the type take the tactile
dimension of so many of these things we
call almond today it's for me very
striking that to see has become very
literally
the same as to touch in many projects
today so in such a perspective many
possibilities may arise for digital
media to relate in this course in this
vital way to the mind and to the body as
well as to the exterior world and this
is where also the progress of interfaces
all these things that the MIT Media Lab
has specialized in to do play a role in
this affair and the hand actually will
be more and more present in the digital
world it's not disappearing to the
contrary it's more and more at the
centre of the digital world I remember
also very well the first time I saw a
student doing this gesture you know
first month of the iPhone was still a
tactile screens were still in their
infancy but this has become a totally
natural gesture today involving the hand
to go in the same direction artist Eric
Nava emotional maps are made based
precisely on the possibility for digital
media to relay information on the
emotional state of the subject who is
doing the mapping so there are a number
of consequences to in all these affair
one is for me the growing importance of
taken by mapping as the prototypical
activity I'm really struck by that what
people do on Facebook very often they do
not delineate their life their life they
map it through photos through the
diverse nodes etc and if you look at
what's happening in design school very
often what you see is a kind of super
abundance of mapping practices prior to
the project and this might be the most
profound change by the way brought by
parametric ISM in some ways I don't see
it necessarily as a style as some in
this conference do and I because I don't
think it wouldn't carries necessarily a
cultural consensus with it but it might
express a fundamental shift in design
from daily nating to mapping the various
parameters involved in the project and
let me remind you that diagrams are by
the in a special case of maps and
strangely we are now in a kind of
totally inverted world in which we map
and the computer daily needs
in some ways so um I will be reaching
the end of this short presentation the
final question like to return is what
might be lost in this affair once again
there is no major technological
evolution without a loss sheer progress
as we know is a myth so what might be
lost in my opinion is a certain kind of
deliberative simplicity
if one substitutes for example will
practice more akin to mapping than to
delineating what may be lost is the
simplicity of the decision-making of the
if you want of the deliberation drawing
was like decision making it had a
straightforwardness with it that is
probably getting lost in the maze of all
these mapping practices that digital
technology enable us to do yesterday
massimo scolari evoked the role of
drawing to ask question rather than to
solve problems but there was always
decision-making in drawing and to draw a
line was already to make a decision on
the relation we had to the world so the
question then becomes of course
something will be lost but we have to
find replacement for it so we may need
to reinvent something reminiscent of the
rapid links the short circuits if you
like between mind hand and
decision-making in the maze of digital
media something like you know the
lightning bolts that would in some ways
go across the thick layers of these new
digitally shaped and saurian something
like if you want the kind of electrical
job enabling this kind of decision made
the return of the simplicity of the
deliberative and this is where and I
will conclude of that it goes back to a
kind of anthropological question we may
need to function in the future at to
various level one which is the reality
of what we've become that is a
multi-layered reality
a complex sensorium in which the
difference between our body and the
exterior world is more and more blurred
in which in some ways you know all these
neo like Nietzschean discourses among
Digital Designer is linked to the idea
that we are no longer separated from the
exterior world we are points of view on
the world so we know that on the on the
one hand but on the other hand we still
need to reinvent a kind of fiction about
the Eroica fiction of the
decision-making empowered individual and
so we may actually have to reinvent the
fiction of man as somebody who makes
decision which means that we may have by
the end to live into culture while which
is the strange disconcerting world of
the digital the world that des
multiplies us sociologists like sherry
Turkle have become very afraid of the
risk of a kind of multiplication of sub
self inside personality so that's for
sure a risk for a networked individual
but this is what we are but we must
probably recreate a fiction in some of
the world in that we still are simple
Minds making decision in a relatively
traditional fashion and I would just
like to conclude by saying that drawing
used for a very long time to be
something that related to both to
reality and fiction what might be lost
today is the relation of drawing to
reality as we knew it but the function
of drawing as a fiction has never been
as urgent thank you very much
great so if I could have the panelists
come back and join me thank you and
while you're not done Oh Andrea Andy
honey I
good afternoon how's the volume okay hi
I'm Jennifer Liang I teach her at the
school and I was very honored to be
asked by Victor Agron and George Knight
to moderate this panel and I know that
we are all very pleased to see such a
vast turnout I wanted to first thank our
panelists for their provocations around
what must seem like an existential
question is drawing dead I appreciate
that this call to arms has produced a
range of response should we resist adapt
or perhaps as Cammie suggests should we
yeah okay should we enjoy the
emancipation I know that several of you
will have questions for our speakers and
we would like to prioritize that portion
of the day after a brief discussion I
hope that all of the speakers would
agree with me that architecture is an
embodied practice it is within our
discipline and tradition that
competitions between the Cartesian the
effectual the post hand/eye and
potentially a new sensorial are played
out and that we are also constrained
productively or not by the codification
and commercialization of drawing it's an
instrument of service a spectacular
image it at least used to guarantee
certain divisions of labor that may no
longer equal agency or even a livelihood
if recent articles calling architecture
the new English major can be believed
sorry Bob at the risk of oversimplifying
I'd like to think that we can challenge
some of the Disciplinary anxieties that
we heard about today if we think about
drying as a site of contamination and if
we as Massimo scolari prophetically
raised last night Antoine again
referenced if we could reconsider the
value of imprecision in the first case
in terms of contamination that drying as
an act of making something flat within a
limited dimension this is something that
bruno latour notes and I would also
include the digital screen in this
making flat this allows for the overlap
of otherwise in commensurate information
forms of notation different ideas
different concepts and scales and this
is a precondition for mastery but
contamination also in the sense of
convention versus exception for example
even before you got to the arguments
today there seem to be two relatively
distinct schema for how to talk about
drawing or how to organize drawings
history on the one hand perhaps the
categorical so if Antoine begins with an
enumeration of the rules of drawing
within the profession holographic
autographic
drawing from nature and johani presented
what to my mind still seems like an
unassailable catalogue of the functions
of drawing as a technology of the self
that is as a form of disciplining and
not to be high daguerreian but of being
in the world the immutability of this
body that draws I think is something
that is also open to get to debate by
contrast cami perhaps put it best in her
survey of an alternative history so if
not a contaminant contaminant than
either adjacent to or distinct from
various hegemonies as deanna also
suggests i find that the selections from
the 1980s as well as the examples of
julia
and Percy that cami places on the
margins of debates about linear
perspective etc and perhaps the question
of the parametric today sit relatively
uneasily against these role bound
functions of drawing either professional
or in terms of how one disciplines the
self and in a sense learns to see so
very simply how do we understand
exception and convention can we think of
the space of drawing as the space of
contamination
Antoine maybe not to put you on the spot
necessarily but where would you place
the drawings of Julia on you or Percy
for example I mean is it really outside
of this spectrum that's narrowing or is
this part of the fiction that you also
alluded to without naming perhaps that
as a role of the profession I think the
the second answer definitely for me it's
part of the fiction and it's part of the
fact that I could also define the
architect as somebody who use fiction to
construct material reality so this would
be where it would definitely fit I was
also struck by another thing which is
the alternative nature and there is
something there also for me which is
interesting I think in some ways are
more optimistic about drawing because I
think drawing becomes between brackets
more marginal than it used to be but it
gives it also you know being marginal
creates new possibility well I mean I
think very clearly cami at least in my
reading of the kind of positions very
clearly states that there's something
joyful or delightful potentially in this
emancipation and I know that your
expertise is in and that another century
when this kind of problematic was also
being discussed but do you agree that
the role is as a fictional role I guess
I would say is something like blade
perspective not also
a kind of cognitive structure a new form
of embodiment is it only a kind of you
know a kind of perversion of conventions
see if I understand the question I guess
um what's interesting to me about the
drawings that I was talking about in
what I see is that their potential
implication for architects now is about
they the fact that they embodied a kind
of Liberty in thinking about the basic
problem that architects face in in
representing space which it's a hard
problem and and they tried the the
architects of the fifteenth and
sixteenth century were essentially
trying various things that kind of
seeing if they worked and that seems to
have stopped for for a long time in in
the way that I I see it of happening
then because because the conventions
were established and they were effective
for the for the things that they were
meant to accomplish but but yes I think
that right now rather than kind of
lamenting the fact that drawing in the
in the construction process will never
be what it what it was that we can we
can actually say oh okay it has there's
a whole world of other other things that
it can do and what would those other
things be well I do decayed sex I guess
one question so if you do say that
there's an Emancipation I feel like
you're maybe it's slightly too quick to
the draw if I could say so that if we if
it's emancipated then therefore we
should go back to our disciplinary
alignment with art and painting so I
don't well I don't disagree with that
necessarily but I think is are there
other if we if it could be emancipated
should we then build new disciplinary
alignments and well yeah
another example that I didn't really
have time to get into but I think it's
interesting and this may speak a little
bit to the kind of direction Antoine was
suggesting but slightly different is
hybridity or the dialogue between the
digital and the hand so that I vote or I
showed that example of the printed book
that had writing and crossing out marks
and so forth as a way of because just
like photography is maybe one earlier
historical analogy for this kind of
digital revolution so it's his print as
Mario carbo has has talked about but in
in terms of what I've witnessed in the
architecture school at Virginia the kind
of some of the most interesting student
work that engages digital design is
often where there's a very close kind of
interplay between model-making digitally
and model making by hand
you know rendering that are then drawn
over drawings that are or
three-dimensional representations that
are that are created using the computer
but then used as a starting point for a
series of other investigations and so
that's one example of something that I
think we may be kind of the debates
become construed misconstrued by
thinking it's you know you have to be an
advocate of one or one of the other it's
actually the kind of hopefully not an
entirely meaningless kind of sidebar but
when the images were going up the slides
were being sort of loaded this is early
afternoon I guess one thing I did know
did note is that these images that were
seeing are already in fact hybrid even
if they were delineate it they've now
gone through the kind of pixelization
which is you know something and I don't
have the citation I'm sorry but I in
1957 in the u.s. the first digital image
appears and it's kind of a utilizing the
photographic grid to pixelate
information
sorry can't do any better than that and
so you know this question of the hybrid
image I also thought was something that
maybe Diana was alluding to although
it's not digital yet but I and this is
maybe a generational position I might
think about the drawings from the 80s
the ones you know they have there
without gravity or just this kind of
collage aesthetic I mean is that is that
a version of hybridity and can that be
something that we could think about as a
way to again in this kind of space of
contamination combine different
notational systems be they metric or
effectual or historically distanced from
us in time something that has gone out
of the conversation today and maybe it's
not appropriate it's actually that
experience of architecture what's about
how experience how we live in and I was
really wanting to ask you and I'm not
answering your question no no please I'm
having a little side effect it's it's
this question that your idea that
drawing is a fiction sure a drawing can
be a fiction but it's also an activity
which is not a fictional yeah okay
that's fine but but at the moment that
drawing and we all say it's it's sort of
old-fashioned to to put it in with the
humanities to do with your human
experience on the other hand without
drawing can you create an architecture
that is actually a place to be well
experienced a place to to fit well into
a city to do all the things that
architecture is going to do is there a
relationship between a drawing and in a
way the humanizing and the human
experience of architecture too I might
say if you can again cut off the sketch
if it's possible I don't know that it is
but if you can in a way cut off the the
sketch the thing that sort of represents
the most creative in the
act how would you now reintegrate it
into the processes because I feel like
what and I believe you said this that
there was something about the sea
reality and the spacing out over time of
design steps and I think you probably
understand this as well from a
historical point of view because you
said it's we sort of overturned it but
is there is there at all a difference
between serial processes that involve
design and I guess literally parallel
processing in terms of computation and I
don't mean that metaphorically I
actually mean it literally in the sense
that if there's a question about how do
we make decisions or I think what you
were saying is that the the the see
reality provides critical distance right
so is is there a relationship and not
really in terms of drawing is it manual
is it digital but in the process by
which drawing is then reintegrated or
sets off a whole chain of design
processes thank you for saving me from a
difficult one I'd like to make two
comments the first I was really struck
by the view of the church at least of a
very famous exploded view because
actually it's another perspective it's
an accelerometry almost all if you Gavin
yeah and that's an impossible point of
view you never see the world like that
around the main same time da Vinci sees
the city of Imola from there again an
impossible point of view that give birth
to the modern city plan so there is
something in growing which is not only
experienced which has to do with the
abstraction of the impossible point of
view and I think growing is constantly
in tension between the two and my point
would be that you know to be human is to
be also partly taking non-human position
no I can see something in axonometry
it's not human so to be and at the same
time it produces very human architecture
so starting from that those premises I
think you know even if already in the
middle of drawing we have non-human
experiential traditional things you know
there are the way to relate to the world
than only drawing actually I don't think
drawing is going to disappear to be
clear but I think there are many other
ways for Aki there
sure to be human than only to grow I
hope just to say that even we in growing
there is a multiplicity of non-human
things in this very and I would agree
with you honey this is the very core
human activity but which is totally
pervaded by non-human points of view
except one and this is what makes also
the price of it they did not answer
directly they are hey I think I agree so
I believe there are two microphones can
I see where they are there's one so it'd
be great if you had a question if you
would please raise your hand of course
and possibly direct a question to one or
two panelists if it works for you just
so we can have more questions are there
really no questions in the back
Thanks hi is this on hi everybody
my name is John Bay Miller I'm an
architect an urban designer I'm 69 years
old unemployed hi everybody it's great
to be back here I live in Portland
Oregon I left New York City intensity
five years ago and moved to the most
civilized city in the country Portland
Oregon and I just came back to Revere
guess who yeah Paul Rudolph in this
building I was here in the 60s I'm a
graduate of UVA class of 65 congrats to
you what I'm holding in my hand this is
the way I still do it
I don't do CAD I try to get through
email every day and I just really try to
get through email every day but this is
it this is the way I still do it
I draw by hand seventeen rendering Mary
glad I'm asking the question to the
audience okay is that here we are in the
building of this master architect and
there wasn't mention of the guy who drew
it by hand Paul Rudolph was the master
of the pen master of the pen and he just
was brilliant and here we are in a
building by Paul Rudolph and they'll
mention the guy who could really draw it
we don't have a half an hour on Rudolph
all right we'll put that on the agenda
next but maybe that raises a little bit
of a point which is about the the space
of drawing if actually and probably I'll
let that go
do we have another question yes I think
this is to treasure pals but a little
bit who was remarkable talk on the hand
on the hand was very very beautiful I
was I was gonna ask him you you ended up
talking about the fingers and the stroke
you you several times set stroke strokes
of the fingers
what do you extend that stroking action
to something which is non planar in your
thinking for example the stroke of the
sculptor or the person who digs a little
deeper into the non flat wall because
the question came up with a flatness a
minute ago that's I think that's a
question do you extend your promise of
the hand to something which is non
planar in your thesis yes I am very
interested in Maryland this notion of
the flesh of the world and in my new
drawing is exactly a very direct way of
being engaged with that that flesh of
the world and when I am doubtful about
certain kinds types of that application
of the computer is my doubt whether or
question rather were does meaningful
eyes in architecture because there is a
tendency nowadays to see to bypass the
issue of meaning completely and see
architecture as
pure manipulation of esterday
aestheticized form but there is not
something that is not me meaning always
has an existential problem it has to do
with human life and in my view drawing
is particularly powerful in escalating
excavating that flesh were meaning can
is it that is a is a I'll ask at a
slightly different way is there a
distinction that you would make between
drawing and carving drawing is is a way
of carving I would say yes yes in your
thesis sculpture the sculpture making of
in the traditional sense correct well I
don't see much difference in fact
between drawing and and sculpting they
and if you read for instance Henry
Moore's fine essays he exactly makes
this this point and this was not my
original observation but another
scholars during the period that
Michelangelo was carving the the Medici
Chapel or the new sacristy his drawings
revert to a 15th century mode which is
cross hatching and the theory has been
and I find this convincing that he's
actually there's a kind of anticipation
of the way that he's going to be making
the making the initial marks carving a
stone so it's an interesting extension
of that I guess Antoine do you do you
know of any I guess contemporary or
coming digital interfaces that actually
behave more like carving perhaps well
once again I don't think the hand is
going to disappear I think pardon so for
for very also simple fact is that you
know today at the beginning we used to
think that the electronic world is going
to be useful to to map and make legible
the real world today we need the real
world to understand the internet
electronic that has been proliferated
and this is all these hand driven
interface and you know I do believe it's
not yet Minority Report
and that kind of you know Hollywood
interface but we are going to toward
more and more tactile dimension in order
to understand the complexity of the
digital world just to another point it's
interesting because I think you could
have a whole other conference about is
not as modeling dead but how is it how
has it changed and I was actually just
talking to some students and people here
at yesterday about how the challenge of
making students understand that modeling
isn't just printing one of the picture I
showed by the way is an experiment by a
guy she at the Media Lab in which you
model and at the same time the computer
captures what you're doing and there is
a kind of feedback loop between the two
which is one of the things that is that
has been exploring that is probably very
into d-block
there's an interesting suggestion by
Adrian Stokes the the British
psychoanalytic writer onarts he divides
for making into two categories modeling
and coffee modeling being additive and
carving subtractive process and he
extends that that difference also to
modes of thinking and I fully agree with
that you know you know that it's a it
was a debate in nineteenth-century
theory the primitive cave versus the
primitive hot which was never solved
what I have not read so far maybe
Antoine could that answer what type of
process thinking process does
computerized support of the tool I think
probably it's a versatile tool it will
not you know you can do primitive not a
digital heart or digital cave can I just
ask you because it seemed to me that
this notion of the tected
now in all our new machine sure it's a
kind of cynicism on the part of an
industry which said everybody was
getting very frightened of computers
pressing buttons what was it going to do
them feelings li let them do this which
is a very rude gesture when you come to
college I mean when people started doing
it I like that that's why the I've had
gesture is very well it's a cynical move
in a way to so-called humanize the
responses of the using of technology it
might be cynical but on the other hand
civilizing you know the use of any kind
of tool doesn't seem to me a bad idea
you know we did that with a hammer a
very long time ago
there's something very curiously
disembodied about this very light touch
where actually you are not making
anything happen in that sense the hand
to which normally the aggression or the
the action of the hand or the other mind
affected the result and how are you
doing all sorts of things without any
kind of fact of reality to it and so
from beginning to end this is a fiction
that's how it's fictional it seems to me
that computers are fictional anyway but
this is a fiction of how we manipulate
them and I think it's a kind of cynical
fiction but as as part of the cynicism
because architects somehow are not
involved in the development of the tool
if that makes sense and we sort of
received them downstream and then we say
oh it doesn't it doesn't actually do
what I wanted to do so therefore do we
adapt do we etc and so maybe this is a
question about the kind of role
disciplinary role in terms of defining
technology or actually how can
architects have more agency in not just
buying software and I'm an expert but
making the demands based on a whole
series of things not going to happen I
think the debate revolve actually about
what is it we call materiality and I
think we forget one thing about
materiality that materiality is always
relational that you know there is
nothing that is material in abstract oh
it's always something in which you have
a relation you know just look at you
know
when I was unable to push the button
that material actually even if it's was
only an image that did not show
materiality is a real relational and I
don't see that many difference in that
respect between what's happening between
bracket in the physical world and the
electronic one it's part of the way we
relate to and make the exterior world
but you know we might not be able to
convince each other I don't tell me I
just wanted to take take up your point
because I think it's an interesting
question I think well some of another
interest more interesting work that I've
seen in studio recently was directed by
an a critic who had an undergraduate
degree in computer science and so she
actually knew how to get into the
programs change them and teach the
students to do the same to tweak them
creatively and and I actually think
that's another really important Avenue
that that is not being explored that
there's too much of an acceptance of
somebody else's authorship and design of
the programs as these are the given
constraints that we have but I think
that there's a whole realm of creative
action and disruption that architects
could do if they built that if they
developed the ability to to either
design their own tools software tools or
manipulate and change industry I mean
they were algorithmic artists just
thinking as you talked about voice
activation and where that would lead the
thing to any interns anymore than you
talk about voice activation yeah okay
yeah well the voice instead of the hand
well I guess you know Antoine was the
last speaker and it
the notion of fiction drawing as a
fiction and you know I can't open think
about the period of time well now we're
three years past the crash but really
this boom that we came out of where a
lot of computation was actually directed
at it in modeling Revit production
building production and drawing became
actually focused on translation to
building rather than expression of
thought or argument or action and
someone I can't remember who showed the
leap skin micro mega drawing it's
amazing drawings that were born and
let's say a period of no building yeah
and a young point in an architect's
career as well although I don't think he
was actually that young when he did that
relative as an architect he was youthful
but you know would it would anyone want
to or antoine maybe to speak to this
sort of you know drawing in in a vacuum
of building let's say this moment time
rat and what that might produce in terms
of manipulations of the digital or
return to drawing as a kind of
exploration around the thought of
architecture rather than architecture as
a tool which I really think is where we
were for
for quite a while that's a great
question one of the most famous passages
of the dictionary of received ideas of
flow Barre is architect forget about
their foreheads the staircase and one of
the reason and actually it may be true
sometimes than one the reason you forget
about the staircase is because a
building is always the projection the
material translation of something that
was partly impossible at the beginning
and in the design process you are in a
contradictory space at certain moment
and so I think in some way so that I'm
not by the end that fascinated but you
know there period in which if we design
more and there period in which the
exploration of the impossibility of
what's Massimo could have called perhaps
yesterday the problem takes precedence
on the exploration of the solution and
there are other periods I think and and
you know I think it's a natural process
and you know of course architecture
there is the economy in it but not only
you know people like they began to
explore you know these between brackets
impossible architecture and with a lot
of remarkable growing at a time actually
in which construction the construction
industry was doing pretty well in the
late 18th century so you know there's no
an absolute connection between the fact
that our cadet begin to do impossible
thing at a certain point it's not that
Street connection historically actually
some other questions
there the other microphone can line them
up only one sorry I'm the only one yep
um I'd like to make an observation to
which I would like you to respond or
react obviously we all know there are
basically two ways of drawing on a
computer and the other is using your
your body whether it's your hand or your
foot or your mouth but the purpose of a
drawing it seems to be the essence of
the issue here is it to sell an idea to
a client is it to raise money to build
it is it because you're an out-of-work
architect and you need to sell a drawing
or is it a tool for the designer to draw
with and so my comment is shouldn't this
symposium be called is hand drawing dead
as a design tool No
I think we're not yet sure we'll see
tomorrow if the digital is alive right
so if I could jump in I mean I think for
us as organizers of this symposium the
issue was and this is Reyes many times
today it's the critical function of
drawing and and how we think as we as we
draw and it it doesn't mean to
necessarily limit a hand drawing in a
sense because I think people still do
hand draw but as some Keith's got to
that we've been in such a state of kind
of manic production as architects and
there's a tremendous anxiety which has
been raised a number of times that we're
working so much really so much and
Antoine talks about the the sanitorium
and the network condition is it so much
as going on that were too busy doing all
these things that we're not thinking
anymore in that sense and for me that's
the notion that the duress and the death
and the sort of decay starts to happen
as in the notion of the drawing and if I
could segue just a little bit to a kind
of question cami started to get to the
notion of the impossible and that she
raised a little bit and I think maybe we
can try and debate this in some sense is
that working digitally hamstrings us
where I feel hamstrung sometimes in the
sense that you can do certain things and
certain nearly impossible things with
programs yet they're still limiting you
because there's a kind of mathematical
or computational condition that's
embedded
so your point I think is is tremendously
inspirational is that how can we start
to its architects take more agency and
break down that process in a way that is
I really truly gets at this fiction
we're talking about right and creates
this kind of invention and it's in a way
if I could circle back again leads us
from this fellow where we're not working
as much that we're attacking and
creating agency and thinking and that's
the that's the fundamental issue and how
we can start to tackle those I mean I
don't I don't quite know how we get at
it yet yeah that's part of the notion
Kyle has a question I don't know if we
can get to him okay in the back thank
you I
I work as a adjunct faculty member
teaching drawing and Photoshop as a
teacher I'm always interested I'm sorry
it's not quite loud enough I'm sorry
anyway I'm we're all kind of in this
either as architects or as professors or
as students as a teacher I kind of
interact on both both sides my students
know digital so intimately even more so
than I could you know I come that back
and I found out that they've created a
Facebook group to talk about their
homework and I didn't even know it how
do we transmit the emotion that we so
vividly feel about the tactile to these
students who so you know work with such
facility in the did
how do we translate this this love to
them last I think that's a really great
and important question if anybody came
to the table with an answer it might
only be that I think
johani mentioned that that there would
be a kind of adjacency at a certain
point between water coloring so by hand
and then a kind of different form of
measure drawing and so maybe I could ask
the question that way is it about an
alignment hand and computer how do you
teach that I'm not sure I completely
understood the question but I think we
have been speaking until now about
architecture as an autonomous thing or
autonomous aestheticized structure but
in my new architecture good architecture
is always relational it's always
mediated it that's the very task of
architecture is mediate between us and
the world and that deals with the
emotional and compassionate aspect which
I find are extremely important and very
much pushed aside for instance in
education it's about mediation and yes
also I would just say to my way of
thinking drawing and being physically
engaged in the process tends to draw in
also these aspects that tend to be left
out in today's architecture ok Antoine I
don't see it as especially dramatic
today for various reasons the first is
any education is it is an indication of
the senses part of it back sandal one's
world restoring the bar and that to live
in a culture is to make a specific
perceptual learning and I think as
educators this is part of what we do I
think in addition to live in a culture
it's not there is not never
way to perceive things because they're
historical strata because even
individuals are constituted you know
there is period in which usually you you
have your thumb in your mouth then the
sound normally yeah you abandon that
habit exactly they're strata and I think
actually what we have to learn the
students perhaps or to suggest is how to
move from one perceptual universe to
another you know touch has not been
abolished but it's in a way extended by
all the ways so we have to teach the
student that you know saw you know to
move in various culture I think in
addition I think this is more and more
the problem today which is to move from
one universe to another and in some ways
for example I loved thesis this semester
for the first time in a long time I've
gone back teaching 17th and 18th century
architecture to explain moldings and the
play of light on the molding is such a
pleasure and actually strangely this is
a generation that is probably better
equipped than the previous one to
understand the mix of abstraction and
very concrete nature of the play of
light on the moldings because they have
this habit of the computer and through
that for example you can relay
traditional touch and the more digitally
oriented understanding things Deanna I
know you taught drawing for many years
and so I wonder if that's a question
that you have a comment on I'm sorry I'm
spaced out for entertaining you so much
well it's a little bit okay I think this
will be the okay Greg we have a question
but last combat end question okay yeah
this is maybe seems like an aside but
the closest analogy that I can think of
is I'd the experience of teaching
digital filmmaking in this context in
which some of the students had had a
background in in tradition traditional
filmmaking and actually editing by hand
so physically splicing things together
and I can tell you that the ones who had
that background were tremendously better
at things like controlling time and
getting a sense of when to end things
because they knew that they had had to
buy their own film and the film is
expensive and so it though there's
something there's something that was
interesting and telling to me about that
even if the ultimately they were going
to become digital filmmakers that the
experience of the constraints that are
physical analog constraints is useful
I'm not exactly sure how to translate
that to your situation but I think that
Greg will have the last question I just
wondered for the panel as historians and
theorists if you have any reflections on
let's say the role that history and
theory played in the 1980s in terms of
drawing and the role it plays now and
also the difficulty in theorizing
drawing I mean it seems like it's a
historian or a theorist talking about
drawing as a topic is a particularly
difficult subset maybe it's not but I
just wondered if you see any effects on
theoretical and historical work that's
gone along with this digital
introduction and and by the way I think
it is all the architects that invented
all this digital technology I mean III
think there needs to be a history of
this technology because I think it's
probably very inappropriate to say that
we receive this stuff I mean it's all
the architects
invented it all not the people in
Hollywood they took it from the
architects hey that's another topic but
I just wonder you know how does this
change the way you do theory what I I
think I just want to make the point
which is Reza's main what I was saying
in my talk that I I think the most
important thing in all of this is a
critique you've returned to history and
in fact all the time I was thinking okay
how do we deal with these historical you
using a nice little example of how you
use history to teach something for the
future that's absolutely fine but
implied in that is also a kind of
critical act which is saying that this
were solutions that weren't just for the
18th century these were solutions that
had possibilities of use in another time
so you were talking you were introducing
about a critique that we don't have to
completely up set up except all the
parameters that are offered to us for
architecture today that we can
participate in a critique and a desire
to change it and and and a desire to
extend in a way my problem with
technology is not that it exists is that
everybody everybody strikes it everybody
says in that absolutely wonderful
instead of saying it's not doing this
it's not offering us a suggestion it's
actually it's actually a controlled
mechanism there are so many other
debates about the controller but which
which haven't come out today so my
answer to all of this is the hand
drawing we spoke about the fifties of
the the the the 89 I don't know if that
was more critical traditional I don't
think it was but a time I think we
probably much more intelligent and they
far more complex debates going on but I
think the the importance was that
something in the hand and I just say
this on Poisson is that it was done with
a hand with the same hand that you wrote
it and I same have that therefore you
read with and thought with and therefore
there was a kind of connectivity whereas
I think very often in the day
we're talking about enormous separations
of identifications of people identifying
themselves with very small groups of
being identified and we I we not
actually seeing a continuity of thinking
planning changing a rather utopian world
of what I think architects ought to be
doing after all you have changed the
world sometimes for the better sometimes
I'd like to go back to to to the
question you're raised because it's a
strange thing drawing in history theory
of architecture because I would say in
some ways it's both central it's so
central that actually there are not that
many good stuff about it I think it's
related to another strange question in
architecture why I once wrote a piece
for perspective that which is why the
question of design method is you know
something we tend to avoid as much as
possible when we do history Theory never
going to write in the middle of that as
if the center of the discipline was very
hard to look at and it's quite striking
that you know by the end all this
fascination with drawing of the 80s has
not produced a huge body of scholarship
and growing there are far more things on
more marginal question and in some ways
I would argue that on the digital there
are a number of issues we don't want to
look too closely at because there is a
similar anxiety I think with the idea
that there is something to st. home as
if architecture had difficulties looking
at it school with a fear that there
might be no poor or the poor is diverse
a lot of question but that's a good
question I don't have the answer as an
historian and theorist but I think it's
a really good question what we're back
to is really the yeah probably the need
at some point to open your eyes and
twice to look at these kind of
incandescent or we know so little about
and then do we have time for one more
question yeah I get the marker the
relationship between the what I would
call the author mmm the idea this
subjective the subject and the idea that
drawing traditionally was a voice from
that subject and through the use of the
digital the the conventions that are
used in connect to teach the digital
there's at least initial the novice or
someone starting in it
the ability to actually only is a lot
more difficult or let's say the path
isn't it hasn't been identified quite
yet I'm not talking about concept of not
talking about scripting I'm not talking
about I'm talking about the actual
legibility of the author through the
touch or the mark let's call it the mark
mark making and what role do you think
and is there a problem in the loss of
the author
well I'm sure Mario will address such a
question tomorrow and this is one of the
question on which we totally disagree
but usually I think it's it's a
fundamental issue today with very
discrepant things on the other on the
one hand there is a kind of hypertrophy
of the author view the world is full of
star architect the world is full of you
know 800 millions or even more of face
book authors so the digital creates you
know a kind of extended authorship truth
is that's probably the big difference is
in the traditional world you created it
ro wing you were the author once and for
all if you want to be an author in the
digital world it's a trajectory and
you're never and that's true that it
goes within instability you know if you
have a facebook profile you've got to
add it you've got to create connection
it's it's always something that has to
grow so that creates an unstable 'ti and
anyway by the end this is a debate we
will probably not solve but it's one of
the real quest
and it's true this is part of the
anxiety which is what's becoming of the
author and and you know there are
various answers condition that she was
talking about is more about a process
and so when you if you can use drawing
to locate the voice and then the problem
is to make the translation but let's be
honest in a media driven Society
authorship becomes the process and it's
no longer a tautology but that was
already true by the way many respect of
architecture before that yeah I think
there are now two interpretations of
authorship sigh I understood your
question to be with simply the presence
of a human individual as the author unit
which you come to whom would you
communicate with while you are
experiencing the building and I think
that's a that's an essential question
and again I would agree with that one
that as a matter of principle there is
no difference between digital methods
and methods but in reality there is for
me the digital digitally produced
buildings usually have an anonymity as
if there was moving human force maker
behind them and also a kind of sameness
resulting from that laser bill
regardless of the perhaps fantastic
elaboration of form I think this is a
very central issue and perhaps the
difference between affluence point and
mine is that I I see very great if in
importance in these minut nuances which
either reveal the presence of human
intention or wipe it away
I think that was just this may not have
been the exact intention of your
question but another angle and this
which I think is interesting is about
authorship as it's changing in the realm
of fabrication and construction and so I
heard an interesting talk by Greg
Pascarella that was about this that was
basically about the kind of dream of
total and absolute control of the
process from that so that there would be
there were no no messy interruptions
between the kind of conception and
ideation and execution because of the
perfection of digital fabrication and so
forth
I found this quite alarming but but what
I think is interesting is that if you
think about kind of early modern methods
of construction there was nothing but
pushback there was a lot of interplay
and pushback between first materiality
but then also all of the kind of Masons
and their experience and this this
distinction has been interestingly
described recently by Marvin
Trachtenberg in building in time when he
talks about Alberti as constructing this
kind of perfect view of authorship in
which anything that disrupts that the
architects idea is can only make it
worse and a kind of medieval and earlier
idea in which the building can kind of
change and shift and it's there is no
single author and it can change and
shift anyway just some additional
thoughts it's like that might be a good
place to end I think that that question
of if not authorship per se but the
questions surrounding the digital and
hopefully some of the problematics we
put forward today will carry over Thank
You Antoine thank